la crise du désir est souvent une crise de l'imagination.
Alors pourquoi la qualité des relations sexuelles se dégrade-t-elle si souvent ?
Quelle est la relation entre l'amour et le désir ?
En quoi sont-ils liés l'un à l'autre et en quoi sont-ils opposés ?
Parce que c'est là que réside le mystère de l'érotisme.
Alors pour moi, s'il y a un verbe qui est associé à l'amour, c'est le verbe "avoir".
Et s'il y a un verbe qui est associé au désir, c'est le verbe "vouloir".
En amour, on veut avoir, on veut connaître celui qu'on aime.
On veut réduire la distance. On veut contracter cet espace.
On veut neutraliser les tensions. On veut la proximité.
Mais dans le cas du désir, on ne souhaite pas vraiment revenir à des endroits qu'on a déjà explorés.
Toute conclusion évidente ne soutient pas notre intérêt.
En matière de désir, on veut l'Autre, quelqu'un de l'autre coté à qui on peut rendre visite,
avec qui on peut passer du temps,
quelqu'un avec qui on peut aller voir ce qui se passe dans son quartier chaud.
En matière de désir, on veut traverser un pont.
Ou en d'autres termes, je dis parfois que le feu à besoin d'air.
Le désir a besoin d'espace.
Et quand on dit ça, c'est généralement assez abstrait.
Eh puis j'ai apporté une question avec moi.
Et je suis allée dans plus de vingt pays au cours des dernières années
avec “Accouplement en Captivité,” et j'ai demandé aux gens,
quand votre partenaire vous attire-t-il le plus ?
Pas attiré sexuellement, à proprement parler, mais quand vous attire-t-il le plus ?
Et à travers les cultures, les religions et les genres,
il y a quelques réponses qui reviennent tout le temps, à l'exception d'une.
Alors le premier groupe de réponse est le suivant : Je suis vraiment attiré par ma partenaire
quand elle est loin, quand on est séparé, quand on se retrouve.
En gros, quand on reprend contact
avec la capacité à s'imaginer avec son partenaire,
quand notre imagination se manifeste à nouveau,
et quand on peuxt l'enraciner dans l'absence et dans la convoitise,
ce qui est un des composants essentiels du désir.
Mais le deuxième groupe est encore plus intéressant :
Je suis vraiment attiré par mon partenaire
quand je le vois dans le studio, quand elle est sur scène,
quand il est dans sont élément, quand elle fait quelque chose qui la passionne,
quand on fait la fête et que les gens sont attirés par lui,
quand je la vois être le centre d'attention.
En gros, quand on voit son partenaire rayonnant et ayant confiance en lui,
c'est probablement ce qu'il y a de plus excitant pour la plupart d'entre nous.
Rayonnant, dans le sens d'être autosuffisant.
Je regarde cette personne - d'ailleurs, en matière de désir
on en parle rarement, quand on se rapproche de l'autre,
à cinq centimètres de distance. Je ne sais pas combien ça fait en pouces.
Mais c'est aussi quand l'autre est éloigné de cette distance
qu'on ne le voit plus.
C'est quand je regarde mon partenaire d'une distance confortable,
quand cette personne qui est tellement familière, tellement connue,
redevient momentanément mystérieuse, d'une certaine manière insaisissable.
Et dans cet espace entre l'autre et moi-même se trouve l'élan érotique,
se trouve le mouvement en direction de l'autre.
Parce que, parfois, comme dit Proust,
le mystère n'est pas de voyager en des endroits différents,
mais de regarder avec des yeux nouveaux.
Alors quand je vois mon partenaire tout seul,
en train de faire quelque chose qui les enveloppe,
je regarde cette personne et j'ai momentanément un décalage de perception,
et je reste ouverte aux mystères qui vivent juste à côté de moi.
Puis, encore plus important, dans cette description de l'autre,
ou de moi-même -- c'est pareil -- ce qui est le plus intéressant
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de nécessité dans le désir.
On n'a besoin de personne.
On ne prend soin de personne dans le désir.
Prendre soin de l'autre, c'est aimer avec force. C'est l'opposé très puissant d'un aphrodisiaque.
Je n'ai encore jamais vu quelqu'un être excité
par quelqu'un qui a besoin de lui.
Désirer l'autre, c'est une chose. Avoir besoin de l'autre, c'est un "tue l'amour"
et les femmes savent ça depuis toujours,
parce que tout ce qui concerne la parentalité
diminue généralement la charge érotique.
Pour de bonnes raisons, non ?
Et normalement, le troisième groupe de réponses est le suivant :
quand je suis surpris, quand on rit ensemble,
comme quelqu'un m'a dit aujourd'hui au bureau,
quand il est dans son smoking, et je lui dis, tu sais,
c'est soit le smoking, soit les bottes de cowboy.
Mais, en gros, c'est quand il y a de la nouveauté.
Mais la nouveauté, ça n'est pas des positions nouvelles. Ce n'est pas un répertoire de techniques.
La nouveauté, c'est quelles parties de toi dévoiles-tu ?
Quelles parties de toi dévoiles-tu pour la première fois?
Parce que d'une certaine façon on pourrait dire
la sexualité n'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait, non ?
La sexualité est un endroit où on va. C'est un espace dans lequel on entre
en soi-même et avec l'autre ou d'autres.
Alors, où ta sexualité te mène-t-elle ?
Avec quelles parties de toi-même te connectes-tu ?
Que cherches-tu à exprimer une fois là ?
Est-ce un lieu de transcendance et d'union spirituelle ?
Est-ce un lieu pour être coquin, un lieu où être agressif en toute sécurité ?
Est-ce un lieu où on peut finalement abdiquer
et ne pas avoir à être responsable de tout ?
Est-ce un lieu où exprimer ses désirs infantiles ?
Que se passe-t-il là ? C'est une langue.
Ce n'est pas uniquement un comportement.
Et c'est la poésie de cette langue qui m'intéresse,
ce qui explique que j'ai commencé à explorer cette notion d'intelligence érotique.
Vous savez, les animaux ont des relations sexuelles.
C'est central, c'est biologique, c'est l'instinct naturel.
Nous sommes les seuls à avoir une vie érotique,
c'est-à-dire la sexualité transformée par l'imagination humaine.
Nous sommes les seuls à faire l'amour pendant des heures,
passer un moment délicieux, avoir des orgasmes multiples,
sans toucher personne, seulement parce que nous l'imaginons.
il suffit d'y faire allusion. On n'a même pas besoin de le faire.
On peut vivre cette chose puissante qu'on appelle l'imagination,
qui est un ciment du désir,
la capacité d'imaginer quelque chose, comme si cela arrivait
le vivre comme si ça se passait alors que rien ne se passe
et tout se passe en même temps.
Alors quand j'ai commencé à penser à l'érotisme,
j'ai commencé à penser à la poésie du sexe,
et si je la considère comme une intelligence,
alors c'est quelque chose qu'on cultive.
Quels sont les ingrédients ? L'imagination, le jeu,
la nouveauté, la curiosité, le mystère.
Mais l'élément central, c'est vraiment ce qu'on appelle l'imagination.
Mais le plus important, pour que je commence à comprendre
quels sont les couples qui font l'expérience d'une vie érotique épanouie,
et qu'est ce qui fait durer le désir, il me fallait revenir
à la définition originelle de l'érotisme,
la définition mythique, et je l'ai parcourue
à travers une bifurcation en regardant le trauma,
qui est l'autre face, et je l'ai regardée
en observant la communauté dans laquelle j'avais grandi,
qui était une communauté en Belgique, faite uniquement de survivants de l'Holocauste,
et dans ma communauté, il y avait deux groupes :
ceux qui ne sont pas morts et ceux qui sont revenus à la vie.
Et ceux qui ne sont pas morts vivaient souvent très attachés au sol,
ils ne pouvaient pas ressentir de plaisir, ils ne pouvaient pas faire confiance,
parce que quand on est vigilant, préoccupé, anxieux,
et sans confiance en soi, on n'arrive pas à lever la tête
pour se laisser emporter dans l'espace, être joueur et en sécurité et rempli d'imagination.
Ceux qui ont revenus à la vie étaient ceux qui
voyaient l'érotisme comme un antidote à la mort.
Ils savaient comme se tenir vivants.
Et quand j'ai commencé à entendre le déficit de sexe des couples avec qui je travaillais,
parfois, les gens disaient, “je veux davantage de sexe,”
mais, en général, les gens veulent une sexualité de meilleure qualité,
et meilleure ça veut dire reprendre contact avec cette sensation d'être vivant,
cette qualité de vigueur, de renouvellement, de vitalité, d'éros, d'énergie
que la sexualité leur apportait, ou l'espoir
qu'elle leur apporterait.
Alors j'ai commencé à poser une autre question.
"Je me renferme quand...” fut une question.
“J'arrête mes désirs quand...” ce qui n'est pas la même question que,
“Ce qui stoppe mon désir...” et “Tu m'excites quand...”
Et les gens on commencé à dire, “Je me renferme quand
quand je me sens mort, quand je n'aime pas mon corps,
quand je me sens vieux, quand je n'ai pas de temps pour moi,
quand je n'ai même pas eu le temps de converser avec toi,
quand ça se passe mal au travail,
quand j'ai une faible opinion de moi-même, quand je pense que je ne vaux rien,
quand je sens que je n'ai pas le droit de désirer, de prendre,
de recevoir du plaisir.”
Eh puis, j'ai commencé à poser la même question à l'envers.
“Je suis excité quand...” Parce que la plupart du temps,
les gens aiment demander, “Tu m'excites,
Qu'est-ce qui m'excite,” et on ne sais pas répondre. Vous voyez ?
Donc, si tu es mort, l'autre peut essayer beaucoup de choses pour la Saint Valentin.
Ça ne fera aucune différence. Il n'y a personne à la réception.
(Rires)
Donc, je suis excité quand,
j'enflamme mes désirs, je me réveille quand...
Mais dans ce paradoxe entre l'amour et le désir,
ce qui semble si énigmatique c'est que les mêmes ingrédients
qui nourrissent l'amour -- la solidarité, la réciprocité,
la protection, se soucier et prendre soin de l'autre --
sont parfois les mêmes ingrédients qui étouffent le désir.
Parce que le désir s'accompagne d'un tas de sentiments
qui ne sont pas toujours du goût de l'amour :
la jalousie, la possession, l'agression, le pouvoir, la dominance,
les cochonneries, la malice.
En gros, la plupart d'entre nous est excité le soir
par ces mêmes choses que l'on combat pendant la journée.
Vous savez, la pensée érotique n'est pas très politiquement correcte.
Si tout le monde fantasmait dans un lit de roses,
on n'aurait pas de conversations si intéressantes sur le sujet.
Mais non, là-haut dans nos pensées
un tas de choses se passent sans qu'on sache tout le temps
comment en parler à la personne qu'on aime,
parce qu'on pense que l'amour c'est l'altruisme
mais en fait, le désir s'accompagne d'une certaine dose d'égoïsme
dans le meilleur sens du mot :
la capacité de rester connecté avec soi-même
en présence de quelqu'un d'autre.
Alors je veux dessiner cette petite image pour vous
parce qu'on naît avec cette nécessité de concilier
ces deux types de besoins,
Notre besoin d'être connecté et notre besoin d'être à part,
ou notre besoin de sécurité et d'aventure,
ou notre besoin de compagnie et d'autonomie,
et si vous pensez à l'enfant qui est assis sur vos genoux
et qui est niché là bien confortablement, en sûreté et à l'aise
et à un moment donné, il nous faut tous sortir
pour découvrir et explorer le monde.
C'est là que commence le désir,
cette exploration requiert de la curiosité, de la découverte.
Et à un moment donné, il vous regarde,
et si vous lui dites,
“ Eh bien petit, le monde est vaste. Vas-y.
Il y a de quoi s'amuser là dehors,”
il peut se retourner, partir et faire l'expérience
de la connexion et de la séparation en même temps.
Il peut se laisser emporter par son imagination, par son corps,
par ses jeux, tout en sachant
qu'il y aura quelqu'un quand il rentrera.
Mais si de ce côté, quelqu'un dit,
“Je suis inquiet. Je suis anxieux. Je suis déprimé.
Mon partenaire ne s'est pas occupé de moi depuis tellement longtemps.
Qu'a-t-il de si bon là dehors ? N'a-t-on pas tout
ce dont on a besoin ensemble, toi et moi ?”
alors, il y a plusieurs petites réactions
qu'on arrive tous à reconnaître.
Certains d'entre nous reviendront, sont revenus il y a très longtemps,
et ce petit enfant qui revient
est l'enfant qui a abandonné une partie de lui
afin de ne pas perdre l'autre.
Je vais perdre ma liberté afin de ne pas perdre ma connexion.
Et j'apprendrai à aimer d'une certaine façon
qui deviendra un fardeau avec des préoccupations supplémentaires
et des responsabilités supplémentaires et une protection supplémentaire
et je ne saurai pas comment te quitter
pour aller jouer, pour avoir du plaisir,
pour découvrir, pour entrer en moi-même.
Traduisez ceci en langage adulte.
Ça commence quand on est très jeune. Ça continue dans nos vies sexuelles
jusqu'à la fin.
L'enfant numéro deux revient
mais il regarde comme ça derrière son épaule tout le temps.
“Est-ce que tu seras là ?
Vas-tu me maudire ? Vas-tu me gronder ?
Vas-tu être en colère avec moi ?”
Peut être qu'il est parti, mais il n'est jamais vraiment parti,
et ce sont souvent les gens qui disent,
au début c'était vraiment chaud.
Parce qu'au début, l'intimité croissante
n'était pas encore forte
au point de diminuer le désir.
Plus j'étais connecté, plus je me sentais responsable,
moins j'arrivais à me détendre en ta présence.
Le troisième enfant ne revient pas vraiment.
Alors ce qu'il se passe, si on veut faire durer le désir,
c'est cet élément vraiment dialectique.
D'une part, on veut la sécurité pour pouvoir vous échapper.
D'autre part, si on ne s'échappe pas, on ne peut pas avoir de plaisir,
on ne peut pas s'envoler, on ne peut pas avoir d'orgasme,
on n'arrive pas à être excité parce qu'on passe notre temps
dans la peau et la tête de l'autre et pas dans la nôtre.
Donc dans ce dilemme pour concilier
ces deux groupes de besoin fondamentaux,
j'ai fini par comprendre qu'il y a des choses que les couples érotiques font.
Premièrement, ils ont leur propres intimité sexuelle.
Ils comprennent qu'il y a un espace érotique
qui appartient à chacun d'entre eux.
Ils comprennent aussi que les préliminaires ne sont pas quelque chose qu'on fait
cinq minutes avant l'acte sexuel lui-même.
Les préliminaires commencent plus ou moins à la fin du précédent orgasme.
Ils comprennent également qu'un espace érotique
ça n'est pas commencer à caresser l'autre.
C'est plutôt construire un espace où on laisse tomber Gestion S.A.,
peut-être où on laisse tomber le programme de management d'agilité,
(Rires)
et on entre tout simplement cet espace
où on cesse d'être un bon citoyen
qui s'occupe de tout et qui est responsable.
La responsabilité et le désir se cognent la tête.
Ils ne s'entendent pas trop bien.
Les couples érotiques comprennent aussi que la passion a des hauts et des bas.
En gros, c'est comme la lune. Elle a des éclipses intermittentes.
Mais ce qu'ils savent, c'est comment la ressusciter.
Ils savent comment la ramener,
ils savent comment la ramener encore
parce qu'ils ont démystifié un grand mythe,
qui est le mythe de la spontanéité,
qu'elle tombera tout simplement du ciel pendant que tu plis ton linge
comme une deus ex machina, et en fait ils ont compris
que quoi qu'il arrive
dans une relation stable, est déjà arrivé.
Une sexualité avec un partenaire stable, c'est une sexualité préméditée.
C'est voulu. C'est intentionnel.
C'est la focalisation et la présence.
Joyeuse Saint Valentin.
(Applaudissements)